[Music]
Nickelodeon's hit show henry danger has
been on the air for more than three
years now at first you might not think
this is a long time but if you compare
some of the cast from then to now you'll
see how much of a difference three years
can make want to see what Sean Ryan Fox
is hiding under his shirt have you seen
what Jase Norman looks like suited up
make sure you keep watching until the
end some of the transformation pictures
may shock you if this is your first time
visiting this channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we're showing you
the cast of Henri danger before and
after Ella Anderson Ella Anderson who
portrays Piper and Captain man is the
youngest actress on the show however
even at the ripe age of 12 years old she
still has a ton of acting experience
under her belt she starred in her first
big gig in 2011 when she was only six
she accomplished so much in such a short
amount of time and by such a young age
really has grown up in front of our eyes
on the screen and lucky for us we'll be
seeing a lot more of Ella since season
four of Henry danger we'll be coming out
soon where she says there'll be a lot of
action and two-parter episodes in
addition Ella is starring on the big
screen this year in the glass castle she
plays the young version of the major
character Jeannette in this major motion
picture she stars alongside big-name
actors Woody Harrelson brie Larson and
Naomi Watts the movie is based on the
best-selling memoir the Glass Castle
the author of the memoir Jeannette wall
commented in an interview at Vanity Fair
that Ella Anderson blew her away in
regard to the thought she put into the
role at such a young age she still seems
very mature and comfortable in front of
the cameras and in interviews it's
likely we'll get to keep following her
exciting career Michael D Cohen the
crazy and weird yet brilliant schwa
Schwartz is played by actor Michael D
Cohen on Henry danger choise is known
for his distinct accent and weird
phrases which sometimes we can't
understand some we can't understand our
choise out and except for my sister who
looks like a horse apparently his sister
is so hairy she looks like a horse can
you imagine although he has played many
other roles Michael is best known for
his role as choir's however as a
comedian he is not a stranger to playing
strange characters as he is credited in
the show Modern Family as the odd
neighbor he also makes a guest
appearance in Disney's Austin & Ally
where he also dresses and acts a bit
crazy although not as wacky as choir's
he was also in a Superbowl commercial
and has tested his skills out as a
rapper if you're a fan of Michael D
Cohen you can actually subscribe to his
personal YouTube channel where he posts
videos of his previous roles if you want
to laugh definitely check it out his
look on an off set of Henry danger are
quite different making him hard to
recognize do you think you would
recognize him if you saw him walking
down the street we wonder if he always
wears such crazy outfits in real life
we'd like to think so mave tamil tea
mave tamil tea plays Bianca and Henry
danger Bianca and Henry are boyfriend
and girlfriend in the show's first
season and drama seems to follow them
throughout the rest of the seasons
namely when Bianca cheats on Henry with
kid danger even though they're the same
people
Bianca didn't know that eventually
Bianca leaves to be in the Henry danger
reality TV show kids in the woods which
Henry's other girlfriend Chloe also left
to be in Henry's losing all his
girlfriends to kids in the woods
rumor has it that Maeve took Jace to her
sophomore homecoming dance
maybe there's a real romance going on
what do you guys think outside of Henry
danger it doesn't seem like May has much
going on in terms of acting but it looks
like she started a vlog on her YouTube
channel she's also a talented singer and
songwriter her biggest project at the
moment appears to be the fashion line
she's designing with her sister the line
is called gem o by M and the Instagram
account describes the line at the glam
Punk apparel focused on female edge the
line still seems to be in the works but
if Mapes personal style of any indicator
we think this clothing line is going to
be Totally Rad
check out Maeve and Jomo's Instagram
account to get a better idea of their
style fun fact
maybethe Canadian just like real downs
who plays Charlotte Jade Pettijohn Chloe
Hartman played by Jade Pettijohn is a
love interest of Henry Hart
she was actually Henry's first
girlfriend in the show but once they
break up funnily enough she seems to
lose interest in Henry and moves on to
kid danger little does she know and
we're not only jealous of her because
she gets to date Henry aka Jason Norman
but Jade also has quite a successful
career as an actress she appears in
multiple other Nickelodeon shows like
School of Rock where she plays summer
school of rock was recently nominated
for an Emmy Award and she was caught
celebrating at the Nickelodeon Kids
Choice Sports Award how exciting to be
nominated for such a major award
she also played McKenna in the American
girl movie McKenna shoots for the stars
this young actress is really making a
name for herself
nearing 1 million followers on Instagram
she appears to have a passion for
fashion
check out her Instagram page for fashion
inspiration and you'll see just how much
her style has matured oh
years trust us you'll definitely want to
raid her closet not only is she a style
icon she's also a sporty girl in a
recent interview she said she loves
volleyball and used to play on a team
she also loves dancing and gymnastics
what a multi-talented girl
Winston's story Trent over-under as Mary
Kay Permenter in crime they both are
reporters for KL VI news fun fact that
you might not have known according to
Mary
Trent's wife left him to be with a more
wealthy and attractive man that's not
very nice we think Trent is better off
without her Trent is known on the news
station for cutting off Mary from time
to time and we're thinking they might
have an off-screen rivalry what do you
guys think Trent is played by Winston's
story
Winston is known for his roles in Henry
danger Brooklyn nine-nine and Grey's
Anatomy
he's been acting mostly in TV shows
since the 90s maybe you guys have heard
of some of these popular shows from that
time the x-files Sabrina the Teenage
Witch and that 70 show he's also been in
another popular Nickelodeon show
Victorious that's quite the resume
according to IMDB Henry danger seems to
be Winston story's main focus right now
in terms of acting Winston also doesn't
appear to be very active on social media
so it's hard to keep up with him outside
of Henry danger but we think he likely
has other responsibilities like family
duties oh well guess we'll have to wait
until the next season of Henry danger is
released maybe this next season Mary and
him will confront each other and work
through their differences Kelley
Sullivan Kelly Sullivan plays Henry and
Piper's mom siren even though Kelly
doesn't have a huge role in Henry danger
she tries to keep her son and daughter
out of too much trouble have any of you
noticed the heart-shaped tattoo she has
on her wrists captain man supposedly has
a crush on her which she appears
oblivious to we wonder if she really
doesn't notice the crush or if she
doesn't want to confront him
maybe she also has a crush on him in
real life Kelly has starred in a number
of popular daytime soap operas including
General Hospital and the young and the
restless' currently Kelly Sullivan is
splitting her time between Henry danger
and another show she's starring in too
close to home
Kelly was nominated for an Emmy Award in
2017 in the category of Best Supporting
Actress for her role as sage Warner in
the young and the restless' she was also
nominated for the same award in 2014 but
that time for her role in General
Hospital her role is sage in the young
and the restless' ended in 2016 in an
interview kelly says she was surprised
when she first found out that they were
going to get rid of her not a great
surprise but she's filled her time again
with her two current shows we're happy
have her on Henry danger Cooper Barnes
Cooper Barnes plays ray Manchester aka
captain man a superhero who recruited
Henry Hart to be his sidekick before ray
was captain man he was a normal boy but
he was accidentally zapped by his
scientist father's experiment leaving
him indestructible
now as Captain man he protect swellview
from evil with the help of kid danger in
an interview with the Henry danger cast
they admitted that Cooper forgets his
lines the most in the interview the cast
also makes jokes about how he goofs
around on set saying he Barnes's around
we were noticing some similarities
between him and his character the goofy
captain man even Cooper admits in an
interview that he's sometimes similar to
captain man although he says captain man
is more quirky and odd than him if you
take a look at Cooper's Instagram page
you can see how close him and Jason
Norman are on jaysis 17th birthday
Cooper posted a picture of him and Jace
with wide smiles in the caption he
wished Jace a happy 17th birthday and
referred to him as his sidekick partner
and friend you should also check out his
Instagram if you want to brighten your
day with all the pictures of his
adorable baby girl Ripley who recently
turned one she is so cute Cooper also
appears to be a huge animal lover and is
an advocate of adopting animals who need
homes what's not to love about him Shawn
Ryan Fox Shawn Ryan Fox known in Henry
danger as Justin Dunlop really has grown
up before our eyes if you compare Shawn
in the early years of the show to now he
is almost unrecognizable only 12 years
old when he started
Shawn has traded in his messy curly hair
for more tamed mature look also have you
guys seen those ABS where did those come
from it's not only his look that has
matured but his personality as well in
an interview with YS B now he has good
advice for young kids about the
pressures of social media he said that
what defines you is you not how many
followers or likes you have on your
pictures we think that's some pretty
good advice it turns out that Shawn is
not only an actor but he also has an
amazing voice and a passion for music in
an interview he said he's enjoyed
performing all his life and his always
saying but is finally pursuing music
professionally you guys definitely have
to check out the music video for his
song indestructible
you might notice him other familiar
faces in the video this artsy guy is
also quite the photographer if you check
out his Instagram page you will find
some cool scenery shots he's taken along
with some drool-worthy head shots we're
definitely looking forward to seeing the
work he does in the future his career is
just beginning
old downs real downs plays the clever
and independent Charlotte Charlotte is a
smart one in the trio
she has quick thinking and is good at
solving problems we're not sure where
Henry and Jasper would be without her
Charlotte is also a great secret keeper
as we can see when she finds out early
on that Henry is kid danger the two of
them are somehow able to keep this a
secret from their other best friend
Jasper real downs is another member of
the cast who has changed a lot since the
first season of Henry danger in an
interview with ysp now Riel says as a
kid she was really shy but has always
loved performing she has a sister close
in age to herself and the two of them
would put on plays for their family
members when she was younger
Riel was in multiple commercials with
her sister and her mother talked about
talent running in the family she also
spills that for to award shows she
actually designed her outfits herself
and plans to do more fashion designing
in the future if you visit her Instagram
page
you can check out her unique and amazing
sense of fashion in the same interview
she gives fans some great advice she
says bu because you are beautiful and
live your life what wise words Riel Jace
Norman Jace Norman was only 14 when he
was introduced to us as Henry Hart aka
kid danger as the main protagonist the
audience follows Henry on his adventures
with Captain man and his friends his
fans have their eye on him not only
because we want to see what Henry Hart
does next but also because Jace is such
a cutie we're pretty sure we're not the
only ones with a crush on him I mean did
you see him in that burgundy suit at
varieties power of young Hollywood event
we followed him through his awkward teen
years but today he looks like a whole
new person Jace is now a young adult and
still has his whole acting career ahead
of him with now more than 2 million
followers on Instagram we're predicting
that you'll be seeing a lot of him in
the coming years Jace has many ongoing
projects outside of filming for Henry
danger he recently started a YouTube
channel where he vlogs about his life
including what it's like to be on set of
Henry danger he even debates the
possibility of getting a tattoo when
he's old enough if you want to get to
know Jace is goofy personality even
better definitely check out the videos
his YouTube videos also showcase his
filming and video editing skills maybe
he'll be doing some videography or
photography in the future just this year
Jace won a Kids Choice Award for
favorite male TV actor so we're sure
we'll see much more of him in the future
and we can't wait are there any of
Nickelodeon characters who you've
noticed have changed a lot over the
course of their TV series let us know in
the comments we love hearing from you
thanks for watching
[Music]